you know how people say a paper cuts the
worst pain you ever drop an iPad on your
face oh you too now recently I came to
an epiphany where Tiffany Stephanie's
noticeable difference right nuts off
nowadays have been getting a little bit
out of hand now don't get me wrong I
believe in treating a woman special and
you know chivalry is not dead
I'll open doors give a girl flowers and
occasionally she asks would give us a
minute
eight medicine in kishka a magnet you
know but the love songs that are coming
out are now [ __ ] up the basis of what
a nice guy should be doing but is it
just me or am i the old one things that
that Bruno Mars song is [ __ ] crazy
I can't just put an a but yeah now that
song became a hit which means that a lot
of girls heard this song know jump out
founders girl everyone having a nice
conversation this stop popped up and she
decided to ask if we were together would
you catch a good name for me run [ __ ]
run
what are we going when you are getting
good names constant leaves on its face
asking me if I may take up bullet in my
brain with your [ __ ] up your bathroom I
think of mother for you we haven't even
gotten to that relationship on yet where
I can fart in front of your permission
did you get spanked huh but who did get
me no my booty just exhale that's all
please don't leave me look if you got to
start with the basis to find out whether
your man is good or not you're [ __ ]
insane
go ahead musician as a question if for
me I'll answer this stuff straight
forward I catch it put names we go no
but
you able to be finished that's cool
whatever gives your mop on the table all
you do is sing I'm trying to have a
conversation
[ __ ] this [ __ ] hey but you look there
that's 30 here's another thing
personally I understand why shelter and
protect under the same title for
qualifications of a man but always
calling me gospel eggs you already knew
this about me hop a little [ __ ] I've
told you this before for some reasons
this needs to be the class plans and
I'll get a women use with [ __ ] goes down
you're my boyfriend
what [ __ ] do you [ __ ] the danger
situation
look everyone get you ever get in a
fight look man that's half my size what
are you always gotta get a punk man who
got like 17 tattoos on his face who look
like you just got fresh out of prison do
you know what's up dude Asian man baby
[ __ ] them do you realize that once a
grown-ass [ __ ] titty [ __ ] that's game
over for the rest of his life don't let
this [ __ ] ain't funny I'll be walking
around the neighborhood did you call me
tips begins [ __ ] I don't want there like
[ __ ] [ __ ] spilled juice on myself you
know that Justin Bieber song is pretty
stupid too we can be starving we can be
homeless we can make money
blood highlights in your concave chest
look imma be honest with you if I'm with
the woman if she caused me to start I'm
leaving her ass immediately must be you
those same lines to see how far I get
haha
Broca's [ __ ] I'm homeless and I got a
half a bag of Doritos chips and a bar
Snickers watch her be like mmm
or whatever broke [ __ ] maybe by today's
low standards I'm not badly enough
Broncos I'm you know group and abuse
bust or selling weaves my whole life
girls right before gets in a fight
hold my purse just me god damn it
it's later on tonight I asked you to be
my
right now because he solves the basis
and standards that women at the diamond